it depends on should women I mean
okay
I don't know if this sounds sexist or
not to the to the viewers but isn't this
sort of show why women get the bad rep
that they get
exactly no no no I feel that this show
this show I'm sorry it almost caters for
misogynist viewers literally because I
agree with pearl to a certain extent my
problem where me and Paul kind of like I
don't agree misogynistic
baby
okay thank you thank you what is the
definition of misogyny I just if I'm
gonna call someone something I know okay
okay right the fact that you just
basically everything that you base and
all the information that you buy okay it
caters literally for men's egos okay
right you basically eradicate every any
sort of words about women
in society in society there are women
who are toxic and there are women that
play a field that basically push this
agenda it's like basically toxic matter
so it's the same thing as toxic
femininity it's just you're basically
the opposite basically let me explain
something the reason why we're asking
you to ex to Define misogyny is not
because we're trying to pick on you
there's a reason we've done this show if
you can look at the the Thomas that's
just my opinion though just one second
you just keep cutting me off we've done
this show this is episode 137 right yeah
and every single time a woman this think
about it how many women are here so
we've done 137 episodes that should tell
you that we've probably had over 600
women on this in this room so every time
a woman has used the word misogyny she
has not known the meaning of the word so
I want to say I told you no you haven't
told us the meaning what's the meaning
oh my Lord you basically I just
basically
tomorrow is like the opposite to
feminism
what is the definition
it's a
it's a success
listen I'm not going because I feel I
know what you guys are basically trying
to sort of do you know I don't know what
we're trying to do we're push an agenda
with a specific type of women and you
generalize all women in that sense you
take away just literally the society we
call it the um oh my gosh
the systemic oppression
this is a woman you do are you going to
answer this question
oh my God I have your opinion and that's
all but here's being with you
can you please kindly tell us the
definition
okay then I didn't okay then then I just
can't you don't use the word again I
mean that's my opinion but we move but
what what what is untrue and this is the
thing I'll tell you why like because a
lot of you know people think that I'm
super hard on women right
um and my my thing is historically women
are just worse than we've ever been from
a historical point of view it's
unprecedented you know what percent of
women are virgins on their wedding days
this isn't misogynistic I'm about to
give you stats I'm about to give you
guys numbers and stuff so so I mean you
could Google them pretty easy it's
pretty simple it's pretty easy one one
is one is I mean this is what the left
will try to do to like discredit you is
they they just question every stat but
it's you can Google them pretty easy
okay so what percent of women what
percent of women do you think are
virgins on their wedding day okay so if
someone wants to be here
[Music]
we're gonna go we're gonna go into this
later but but I want to say what percent
of women are virgins on their wedding
in the west all right can we can we
answer the question what would be about
25 25 okay who who thinks it's higher
what percent of women have been on birth
control at some point in their life
90.
okay okay we're okay fine which is all
good and well until we start looking at
the body count statistics where the
where after a woman has had five
Partners her chance of a happy marriage
drops to 20
okay so and the average woman has slept
with more than five men okay which
remember historically a hundred years
ago 85 percent of women were virgins on
their wedding nights now what else does
the men get out of marriage they get
loyalty but not today because half of
women leave
then then we start to go into weight
where women are overweight the average
woman is five three hundred and seventy
pounds these are just numbers and yet we
scream misogyny at me but these are
these are just numbers now I'm and it's
like I can't say numbers without being
called sexist when they are true
I'm family therapist and they make big
research and I have a lot of numbers
eighty percent of women I decide to
divorce
that women choose but women choose from
Men Who choose here
women choose but first for example if
you have one room and you have fun five
men from these five men you choose men
who choose you one might make you sick
now I like you I smile you you go and
you choose from man who choose you if
men don't like you if not has sex
attraction you cannot do anything first
men need to go up and say I want this
woman and then you choose from Men Who
choose you first second you're totally
right we are women I make my book about
entrepreneur and it's absolutely in
numbers we are women we are not so smart
like men we cannot make many things
which make men never ever because our
brain is different it's different we
cannot we cannot run so fast we cannot
make some big numbers you are totally
right that the business which make we
are women it's psychologist coach and
Beauty it cannot be my old man and if a
woman for good she's a woman she become
to be sick every day work with women who
cannot be pregnancy today is the biggest
problem in our society in UK and what
they are do they become to be men she
have a lot of courteso she has opinion
about oh this is it messes up to be a
feminist and after she came to me like
family therapist Natalia I want to be
pregnant what you do 40 years you hate
men you hate your father you try to show
that you have big balls and after
yourself I want to be a woman what you
did before you need first to be a woman
and woman it's a totally different
Quality quality which you need to
survive as a man you need to be strong
and we know usually what woman today
tell to me Natalia I want to find the
man which very kind very rich very good
looking very sexy love me like a crazy
he's a very crazy to accept my child he
want to take care about him about my
child he wants to marry me and from some
reason he's single in 40 years old
and of course she couldn't find it after
she is very disappointed and you are
right that woman choose but probably
that women have too high expectation she
want to be a princess she doesn't want
to change herself to go to fitness to
take care about how she looks how she
speak with men how she listen man
because the woman must listen not to
speak you need to speak 10 and 90 you
need to listen and to speak exactly
admiring admire your man admire to him
admire him and about Sin down separation
has big difference you can be separate
with your partner but he continued to
help you he continued to help your child
he continued to take care about you he
continued to be your best friend and to
call you every time when you need him if
you make normal relationship you must do
divorce only when you have Financial
dependence loyal Independence your
emotional stability you love yourself
you are a love your partner but you can
develop because you say I want something
else and you continue to say your child
your father is the best man in the world
and your child if he can be divorced but
he can love both of parents and not have
psychological trauma you can be in
marriage to be in toxic relationship and
you can destroy your child a woman must
to love it's the most important mission
of women which forgot not compare with
men you are not a man you are a woman I
agree with that can I follow on from
what you're saying I I agree with a lot
of what you're saying in the terms of
when women and men were physiologically
different mentally we're different our
brains are wired differently I think men
crave and demand respect even in
marriage if I don't respect my husband I
can't expect my husband to love me in
the way that I want to be loved if I
don't give him the respect there's a
book I read I can't remember the artist
the artist the author's name it's
literally called respect and love and if
you don't give each to the other one the
other needs and what the other ones it
becomes a crazy cycle so if I don't give
my husband the respect he's not going to
love me the way that I want and he will
give me love but ultimately he wants me
to respect him and not a respect that I
should be submissive and oh yes sir you
know kneeling on the flurry time he says
jump in and say oh how high no he needs
to give me a level of respect back too
can I say it will only work if you love
and respect yourself 100 can I just
carry on from what you mentioned when I
um when I started to live with my
husband he said to me that you need to
you need to remember that you have a man
because I'll do things like carry all
the bags independent independently buy
myself to the door and he'd say why
didn't you call me so it's just learning
little things that I had to do to be
more feminine and understand that I am
in the marriage and there are roles I
know people don't like to
um the terminology of gender roles but
sometimes they are in in a marriage or
in a relationship where men need to feel
like they are men they need to feel like
their woman needs them to some extent
and that's what I had to learn I had to
learn I had to relearn how to be
feminine because I was single for so
long I kind of forgotten it by yourself
yeah I've kind of forgot how to depend
on a man I had that with my father Oh
Daddy please Daddy please oh yes yes yes
and he'd give me whatever I wanted but
that that's also the sense of him being
needed my father knew that I needed him
and he provided so it was the same in my
marriage I need you and he provided but
when I don't let him know that he's
needed like me getting up on a chair and
trying to change a light bulb myself I
know how to do it uh-huh baby can you
come and please you know I don't really
want can you yeah of course he'll come
and do it so it's those little things
that also add to um to making your man
know that you do need him you might not
well you might not need him but you
allow him to feel needed even though you
can do it and that's kind of the
feminine femininity and masculinity in
the relationship the the yin and the
Yang that goes together collectively
Pearl I would like to just stand up for
your show
um I think they're trying to essentially
say that this show is promoting misogyny
when literally all you did was give all
of these ladies a platform to speak on
it's it's not Pearl's fault that there's
these ladies speak the way they do
for example for example the lady over
here is screaming misogyny yet she
doesn't even know the definition
you know exactly why I meant by carry on
I don't have to take a dictionary if you
know what I don't have to say to you in
a dictionary English word by word you
know exactly but what I mean but the
reason why you know I just said to you I
basically reply to you is when you take
away where you basically don't
acknowledge don't acknowledge a woman
women go for it a systemic it's almost
it's very that's one male side
it's a form of Oppression it's a form of
Oppression towards women misogyny has a
specific definition
what is it then tell me it's education
I need to reiterate the rules because if
you keep doing this you'll be kicked off
the show unfortunately but the reality
is
whether you like it or not language
exists for a reason women keep talking
about oh communication this
communication that women are better at
communicating than men yet
in the same breath you would say a word
and misuse it and then still argue that
what you think it means is the
definition when it clearly isn't Okay
the reason why I can confidently say
this is because like I said before this
is episode 137 we've done this show 137
times and every single time a woman has
used the word misogyny we have come to
find out that she doesn't know the
meaning so is it wrong for me to be able
to now make an analytical logical
conclusion that you probably don't know
the meaning as well what's your opinion
it's not an opinion that's your opinion
this is how science is is propagated
unless you gave you examples of it by
you know an example definition if I want
to ask you what's the definition of a
woman I'm sure you probably don't even
know that as well
Allah
I think it's too much
seconds
do you know the crazy thing is you've
talked more than anyone like you've
talked to the most of the show out of
all the guests you I'm not even saying
anything no you were just talking the
whole show and you'll say it to me
pushing an agenda I can't make words
come out of your mouth and the crazy
thing thing is I'm just so tired of this
narrative that women are oppressed in
any way women are not ever met women are
more likely to get custody of their CH
of their children women are more likely
to get child support alimony men are
more likely to commit suicide men do the
hardest jobs men are the majority of
workplace deaths and yet women will live
in a society that men built and cry
misogyny and oppression
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible